[Music]  release the log  yes  [Music]  oh  uh  [Music]  my brother gave his life hunting the  enemy  his task is now mine  [Music]  stand with me  ours was no chance meeting  searching  not fate  nor destiny  ours was the work of something greater  [Music]  each of us  must decide who  we shall be  i am not the hero you think  whatever it was you did  be free of it  one day this will be your kingdom raise  your sail  and then let go  she's not the path of fear  but that of faith  [Music]  one thing we can do  better than any creature in all middle  earth  we stay true to each other  with our hearts  even bigger in our feet  [Music]  i can survive this  you and i  commander wait no we keep moving  why do you keep  there is a fighting  in me  [Music]  you have fought long enough  put up your sword  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  without it what might be  [Music]  [Music]  you